Hello. I had a very productive Saturday
and then I kind of crashed and I'm
pretty out of it
here. But I think what we're going to
try to do
today, I just want to fix this port.
Basically, we have this uh this version
of Puffer. We have this environment.
Uh, it should not have stopped working,
but it stopped working somehow. So, if I
can just figure out what the heck
happened
here, that would be a very good start.
Let me get a reream open at
least and we'll kind of just chill and
right. you had the discussion with that
student yesterday. He's reading your
blog. Oh, cool. I didn't realize he was
one of your contributors. Very
nice. I mean, I 19 is that's about how
old old I was when I started the uh the
version of neural MMO that
um led to my thesis.
thinking of is it the guy in the discord
who made the bullet hell or is it
someone
else? It's not that
one. Well,
okay.
Well, regardless,
um I think 19 is plenty old to do just
about everything except have any social
context on anything.
printed everything.
Yep. All
right.
Um, let
me go grab the run
command for this
go. From your blog, you
quoted greater than 1 mil SPS single
CPU. Wait, single CPU. single CPU
runs. Wait, from your blog, what did I
quote? Let me find this command and then
I will look at it while this runs.
Um, let me just find this command real
quick.
2.0. Oh, do you just mean the
graphic or the blog post?
you. Yeah. So, it's
the environment itself. a lot of our
actually I think all except maybe like
go with uh really like tuned up AI but
yeah the the M should run over a million
steps per second. Um there are
improvements coming to that but that's
going to mainly just be on how well your
environment is
implemented. Obviously we also can
multiprocess so this can go way faster.
There should never be a
bottleneck. And yes training has gone
up. It's now um most of our M it's like
500K to 2.5 Now
I'm trying to figure out why this no
longer works.
Welcome. Is this policy actually getting
run? I'm worried it's like skipping
layers or something
ridiculous. I can't think of why, but
it's like I don't know what else would
be wrong with this.
For context, what we're doing here, this
is so this is a version of Puffer Lib uh
that a collaborator is using and they
wanted me to like port a bunch of dev
features over and now the policy no
longer trains quite as well as before.
So, we're trying to figure out what's
broken.
Okay, so the initial obs are all the
same. Doesn't that seem
wrong? The initial logits are all the
same? That would mean the initial obs
are all the same.
Did you solve any robotics m with
puffer? Last I checked you were on some
humanoid RL. Yes, we did
um animation generation for a client
which was like you have noisy like
generated animation data that might clip
through the ground and do weird stuff
and then uh you run it through is gem uh
and you run puffer on it and then you
get out an animation that is no longer
like clipping through the ground and
stuff. we delivered
that. As for like other stuff in
robotics, it's mostly contract based,
right? So like we'll do more robotic
stuff when either a we have contributors
who are interested in doing robotic
stuff who want to like you know add in
some other ends and hook up some
experiments or b you know we have a
another client in robotic space who
wants to do more in there. Other than
that, we kind of just do core general
purpose RL and then we go into specific
applications, you know, as they come
up. Like for instance, the new stuff I
added with Muon and cosign analing um
plus like some of the perf enhancements
that's going to just apply to
everything.
zeros? The obs are all Oh, no. They're
not all zeros. Okay.
Where's numbum
workers batch
size 192 kind of juggling between a
rust ml and
math. So I did um I did the Andrew like
course stuff uh when I was that age
maybe a little younger. It's if you look
at like the Corsera stuff it doesn't
include any of the modern neural net
like any modern neural net stuff and
it's just a bunch of math and then if
you look at like 229 it's even more
math. Um what I would highly suggest is
like
231N. It's going to be a way more
accessible course and it's going to
teach you a lot more about like core
modern neural net stuff. You implement
as part of that you basically you
implement your own autograd and then you
will actually understand how these
things work way better than the vast
majority of people using
them. I mean my my blog post has this
right. I highly just suggest checking
out that blog post. It's uh I try to
make it a little easier.
This stuff was a hell of a lot harder to
learn, you know, several years ago, but
there's some good resources now.
here? Numb
workers. I guess that's set.
based on the box.
Hey, Spencer. I'm stuck debugging this
thing. I'd like to go do some of our
info work, but
Yeah, let me double check. I think that
that's saying
state. Does this not up? This one should
update, right?
Maybe this is what I screwed
up. You share
the So, I mean the blog I linked before,
right, should
have have a full
guide. If you just go on puffer.ai,
right, I have this quick start guide and
this kind of has all the references in
here. But if you just look up
CS231N, it's this course and these
videos are all
online. This is 2016. So this is still
good.
Um I yeah, I think you can find like
more recent ones as well, but I would
suggest either Carathy's lectures or
Justin's lectures.
They're the uh the best lecturers on
this. That would be my suggestion. You
should also actually do the exercises
for
this. I think that they released
those solutions.
Mind you, I generally tell people to
only spend like 20% of the time they're
going to allocate to uh to RL on formal
material. Like spend 80% of the time
actually doing stuff and spend like 20%
of the time on formal material.
Is this
it? Wait.
TD
state. No, this looks
right. You're recruiting
uh you're recruiting people to help you
with your physics, RL.
I mean, I will say I've somewhat trained
uh a few good few folks in
here. Flying to the real world is where
the money is at. Well, we do that as
well, right?
folks. Currently just attempting to
debug
uh this port of Puffer onto this other
library. And then after this, we're
probably going to do some depending on
if we can fix this in a reasonable
amount of time. Uh there'll probably be
some cool infredev on the the new C
bindings, the new C binding system for
puffer
ms that really well over the weekend,
but still needs some
anything, but I'm curious to see if this
runs.
like the performance dips but it still
trains.
If I messed up something as fundamental
as like the LSTM state,
um, Perf should be totally
crashed. There really not that many
things I can think of that I could have
screwed up that would cause like a small
but very noticeable dip in
performance. Most successful applied RL
cases you've seen.
Doesn't DeepMind use them to like cool
their data centers or whatever? Wasn't
that one of the big ones? Um, I mean, a
lot of the robotics control
stuff, right, is using
RL. Uh, what the heck
else? I think there's some stuff in like
traffic navigation. Yeah, there's some
stuff in traffic uh traffic control.
Uh there's the driver routing thing from
Lyft, assigning drivers to uh to riders
with Lyft. The thing is it's like a
whole bunch of just random things. It's
not like oh yeah, it's just for this one
industry, right? It's just a whole bunch
of random
things. And that's not a bad thing. It's
like it's got, you know, diluted but
like
broadreaching applications.
What was their atom epsilon
before? I guess we'll look at
that. Go check their atom epsilon. I
think it was just one e minus 5
though. I think I have that matched.
Yeah. One E minus 5 right there. It's
hard coded.
I'm looking for
like hyper pram that's all like clipping
that's done differently like something
So somewhere in here I messed something
up I guess right
Is it possible that I have theuler
screwy
somehow? It seems like it's more
fundamental than
that. Maybe not, though.
It could be an ID screw up though. I
checked
this masking screw
reward clipping isn't in the original,
but I already have that
commented. You would think it would be
something like reward clipping, like
something like small like but
substantial. It didn't seem like it
though.
I mean like there's a lot of code
changed but most of this is behind like
this doesn't ever get called
and this is the
same up
Eight. See how their original
worked. They have LSTM state is none.
LSTM
state. So this gets reset each
epoch. Do I reset each epoch?
difference? Where do we reset
um LSTM state and
train? I'd be really surprised if that
were a difference.
No, see I manually set it to none right
there.
No, they have right here + 1
egative8 in their norm as well, don't
they?
Okay. And this is all unmodified. I
didn't mess with this.
I do mean the losses,
right? I should probably make sure the
loss is a scalar. You get way more of a
slowdown than I'm seeing here,
though. If it weren't, I'm pretty sure
I don't want to get my hopes up that
it's suddenly working
here. Um, yeah, this could very well be
stuck as well.
Still, I don't know if I'd run it with
Adam epsilon before,
though. Let me
see. So, this is the previous
run. Yeah. know this. See this is Adam
epsilon 205. So this is still
uh going to be the same thing most
likely
really. You'd think that it would have
been like
some Okay. Well, this one here was with
1 eus 12 epsilon. So, the original
baseline
uh was with a different epsilon.
Right. But everything else is the same.
So the only change there's also theuler
which should be off. So I should double
check the
scheduleuler and then there's the
epsilon.
See, I'm pretty damn sure that I ran
this exact experiment already,
though. Yeah. See, that looks like it's
going to get just stuck right there. We
got to let it run now,
but I wouldn't have too high hopes
that's going to just magically solve it.
change? So, reward flipping is off,
right? In fact, I kind of want to
compare this version
to this version here.
Okay. We've double checked. LSTM is
getting assigned correctly a ton of
times.
Done mass equals D +
T. But you store DUN
here and here you store reward
done CPU and by
mask by
D. Destroy the
mask. You get O and O
device. These should be the same,
right? Yes. These are exactly the same.
This would seem the same to
me. Neither of these has reward
clipping. Neither of these has any other
tricks.
And we'll just double check that store
doesn't do anything
weird. Yeah, they don't do any clamping.
They don't do any weird stuff in here
either.
Then in their
train we
have
indices. See where they
get
done.
rewards. Uh we don't get
values. We do have values right
here. And
then these go to CPU.
I should probably polish up some of this
stuff. But then dun's values rewards
gamma. Effective gamma is config gamma
and then
lambda. Then
returns is advantages plus
values. So we should look for this
should add values.
Right. The advantages plus the values,
right?
frack right here.
Config norm
advantage. This is
identical. This is
identical.
Why is my curve so much more jagged than
his?
Wait.
T. Okay. So, this is what he got with my
atom right
here, which is about close to what I
have. Then he got this with the base.
That's definitely a different curve,
right?
theirs interestingly their value loss is
worse.
There procs kale of
course this is a hardware difference so
we don't care about that too much.
similar. Their entropy crash is faster
as
well. Uh they don't log gradient
variance.
We should double check the learning rate
real quick.
like some jank clipping or something
going on.
That's not It's not the optimizer being
different. So the torch implementation.
Yeah, this is the same
What about parameters? Is there some
like parameter not getting applied the
same
Oh, well wait. No, this should be the
same for both. I have a different number
of pores on this machine.
I should run the main to be sure because
I do have It could be just the clamping
plus the
uh Yeah, it could technically be the
clamping plus the epsilon fix.
This optimizer prim no longer
exists. We do
this.
Yeah. I'm going to make sure this runs
and I'm going to be right
back and uh we will
have what should be a repro in a few
minutes.
This will be good because I can check
the step per
second on my box as
well. Yeah. Okay. Be right back.
faster. So far, this thing matches the
uh original curve pretty close. We'll
see if it takes off or not.
I mean, it looks worse by all means.
It's like this is somehow some like
ridiculously overoptimized
It's like so freaking close, but no
cigar.
Does it keep going up if you keep
running
five and maybe the performance numbers
tell me something about what I screwed
as
well. So
Miss
time is way lower for mine.
higher. Wait, hang
on. Am I reading this
right? So, performance train time
training and more time in
eval. Okay. And then the learn
time, the learn time is pretty close
actually.
time. That suggests it's a different
model, doesn't
it? Hang on. that suggests that it is a
different
model. There's no other thing that would
explain that,
right? How possible is
that? There's also this massive stack of
miscellaneous time.
So now I probably screwed something up
here.
So there's a massive stack of
miscellaneous time and a noticeable
forward time
difference. Train forward is a pretty
small function, isn't it? Just has like
one thing in it.
Yeah. So train forward literally just
does
this just pulse the policy and then
detach and then
synchronize train has a bunch of
stuff. It's totally possible I messed
things up with over there.
Yeah, but this does track the older
proc, doesn't it?
clipping? Well, no, because the the runs
still look different, don't they?
The metrics still look very different.
Hang
on. So it can't just be that
right. Your approx is totally
different. A lot of metrics are
completely
different. So there is an issue.
Somehow the model that I ran
now it's taking more time to eval but
less time to
train. More time to eval but less time
to
train. Okay, hang on. There could be a
timing difference
though. There could be a timing
difference.
So this includes
sampling and the LSTM stuff. Okay, so
this is going to cover that. But then
the fact that it takes longer during
training
Yeah. So when I run this, it doesn't
even run any
Um, wait, wait. Isn't this a problem?
What the
bashed? Wait, this isn't freaking
bashed.
This must be in a different spot. I must
have two break
points. That wouldn't make any sense.
Yeah, that's got to be it. I'm
confident.
Oh yeah, that that's immediately
changing the
metrics. And now it's a bit faster.
Yeah, it's a bit faster as
well. All
right. That's
obnoxious. Well, we'll run it with Muan
and stuff after to see if we just crush
it. Holy, that's annoying.
speed is now way closer to the
uh where's it? So, it's this
one which was my
baseline. We've got was it this
one? Yeah. Now the speed is about the
same. Let's see if there's anything that
tells us early on
metrics
different. I think we got to at least
wait for the approx to take
off and then we'll do move on. So, I
mean, we'll be done with this an hour
and then we'll be able to merge this in.
I can go get myself cup of tea or
whatever. We can start on the next
stuff.
Yay. Well, that's an annoying bug to
find.
Um, I'm going to keep going on this at
least until I queue up the next
experiment and we will uh then shift
gears back to
infra.
So, man, that's that just annoys me so
much.
Um, hopefully this is actually the fix.
But yeah, so on
infraside, I guess we go look and see
because I think there was a training
difference with one of them with one of
the
M's. We'll play with
that. Oh, yeah. I know it's this one's
lower. You see the entropy is going down
faster. This is definitely
it. Maybe we can just start on the in
for now and let this run in the
background. Even better, right?
Oh yeah, there we go. That's totally
different.
Well, I find it difficult to
different. Well, I find it difficult to focus on two things at the same time,
focus on two things at the same time,
but um I will see if I can let that go
in the background for a bit and just try
not to think about
it.
Here, I'll put it literally behind
me so you can watch it.
So, why did I get rid of the Syon
version of
this? I just couldn't get it to compile
or something. There was some weird bug.
Bugs! Um, there's no more log buffer,
right? Or log
law. Probably just copy all this over so
I don't screw it up.
This is all getting deleted anyways.
This is just so we can test perf and
make sure that we actually get uh know
some kind of perf
So, we will uh we'll get this PF
benchmark going. While this finishes
running, I'll run muon in the background
and then uh we will hopefully move on to
porting like neural MMO or one of the
more complex MS.
enum? Whatever. We'll just hardcode this
to four. This is a quick test. H, this
is a quick test
No
[Music]
module.
Okay, we'll just we'll just uh for now
And actually, this is a good timing
because I'd prefer to run this test
without the other one
running. Uh, we can't time the logging
unfortunately.
But this should at least give us
something. This also might be compiled
in debug mode, so we might have
to fiddle with
50 million. So I suspect that this is in
debug
mode. Yeah. So I have - O00 on here. So
that's going to totally screw us up. I
think let's put them at both O2.
Okay. And now we're going to kill this
perf test so we can run this other one.
is it says this is
slower. Let me see what flags I have
because it should not be there shouldn't
that shouldn't be possible.
Do I see the building here
somewhere? I do, but I see
welcome. Didn't reach out on Saturday.
Oh, all
good. I ended up coding all day
anyways. Did start going over puffer and
trying to use it. Awesome. Yeah, let me
know if uh you know there are any pain
points or if anything doesn't make
sense. It's supposed to be very easy and
simple and if it's not, there's probably
something wrong.
Everything worked on Debian on Mac. I
ran into some
troubles. Well, to be fair, we do test
it on uh Linux most prominently. We do
have Mac tests. Um but there are a
couple weird things on Mac OS. If
there's anything that's like easily
fixable that I could just merge in, feel
free.
Only back end that
worked was with was the
serial. That's
weird. So, multiprock should definitely
work on Mac. It should not work on
Windows, but we don't have official
Windows support anyways.
Um wait post number three is that you
are using the 2.0 release
right the latest
one. Okay. Cuz that old that post isn't
that like a super old
Um, this is super old. Like we've
rewritten the vectorzation since
then. The docs have it
three. But this is this is the latest
one right on the dock specization.
Something like this.
You're all
good. It's supposed to be this easy
here. Are there error messages on
something that I've missed on the
Discord?
example. Okay, you didn't get this. I
imagine that's like that is a max
specific numpy thing, but I that
shouldn't be
vectorization. Send the code. I'd like
you to post if you link the code and uh
if you post the full error
message. Yeah, just post the full error
message here and I'll look at it right
now with you. I mean, that's half of why
I stream, right? Is so that I can do
that. Let me run this in the background
if I'm going to be doing this for a few
minutes.
one. It's got to be between these two
then.
Oh, wait. There's D and D bug is in
here. It's in here as well.
good. This is what I mean though when I
say it's easy to get help in puffer lip.
I'm like I stream 40 to 60 hours a week.
So it's like if you get
stuck, don't hesitate. Right. half at
least half the time it's like something
screwy that I've
done or something that could be
documented better or whatnot.
Try
this. I'm trying to see if it's a
problem with Atari or if it's a problem
with Puffer.
Wait,
spawn that change. You're on the 20
branch, right? Or are you on dev?
Um, that would be really
weird because
that's if that's a thing then that's Mac
being stupid.
it. I'll add a note to the docs if
that's a
thing. That'd be
nutty. All
right. Yeah, I I'll add a note. But I
don't know what I can say other than use
a real operating system. Holy hell,
Mac. What is that?
It should be uh cork fork is the default
on Linux and I think that this thing
should train the same with spawn. I
actually don't
Is that a worthy
PR? I mean, I can just go set that right
now in uh the dev branch.
Lord. Perfect. I get to go PR that thing
right now.
Shall I should I try pulling the dev
branch? No. The dev branch has a lot of
stuff in it. Uh and I break the dev
branch constantly. So if you're not
contributing to puffer liib or like
actively trying to do cutting edge stuff
with it then you should probably stick
on
that. Debian
crashed. What do you mean your Debian
crashed? If you set the uh the start
method
don't What's your terminal
theme? Uh the terminal theme or the Vim
stuff you can get this um just in puffer
tank. It's just it ships with our
containers by default. It's just my
personal uh my personal color
scheme. I don't know. Some people like
it. Some people says it pains their
go. This is my whole
config. So like the meme of spending
five hours configuring Neoim, like this
is literally it. Half of this is just
the color scheme. And I have like a
couple extra highlights for Python
because like Python's kind of hard to
highlight since it's
um dynamically typed. And then I have
Super Maven. That's it. Two
plugins. I got literally
two. Sami is I literally only need this
for Python as well. Like you don't need
this in C. And uh Super Maven is the
only one I really like.
I really like that I can just download
Puffer Tank anywhere. So I just have my
container anywhere and I have my entire
development environment on the
container. So you know I don't have to
like connect something to it. Just dev
on anything. Super easy.
I haven't edited that file in
months. Are you sending me down another
rabbit
natively? Well, you kind of want
containers for Puffer
Tank,
right? So, the the cool thing with
Puffer Tank, right, is you've got the
whole workspace. We have all these
different machines as well, right? So,
like if you see the
blog, we've got all these machines and
they all just have the same base install
on them, which is literally just drivers
and whatever and um tail scale so you
can access them and then you just put
the containers on them and it's like
somebody needs to use the machine and
doesn't want to have like somebody
else's messy workspace, no problem. One
command, you spin up your own container.
It takes 5
seconds. So, it's just a really, really
easy way to manage
these. You're kind of like AWS. Well, we
have some machines, right? And we use
them for dev. We use them for
contributors. Contributors get access to
some of these. We're going to get more
of them as well.
We don't like rent them out. We use them
for our own
updated. I just made the change, but I'm
doing a ton of stuff, right? I've got
like a messy state.
Yeah. Yeah. Just try
it. I mean, you can just paste it at the
top of your file and it'll do the same
thing,
right? Let me just make this PR real
quick and then we'll go back to
infrodev.
1100 members hit in uh Discord. Can we
hit 2K stars now? That's the
question. 2K stars would be awesome.
There you go. So, I don't know why the
start method is different on Puffer. I
mean, on
Well, Windows just doesn't support fork
is the thing. So, it just won't work on
Windows. Okay. This doesn't make any
sense to me why this is slower.
I'm a little
um confused as to how it's possible that
this
is not faster.
matter, which it shouldn't. Looks like
one file.
Well, these aren't checked though. So
the thing is it needs to actually run
That's
So, the thing I'm confused is this
shouldn't be
possible because
um Syon has like a ton of overhead.
keywords. What are you working on?
Freshly graduated data scientist. At
least that's what my degree claims. Uh,
your stream just popped up for
recommendations. I thought I'd drop by
and ask. Well, you can do more than
that. There's Whoops.
Puffer Puffer.ai. You can see a bunch of
our demos. So, we've got all these
different environments. These are
essentially just very high performance
games. They run at millions of steps per
second uh if you don't render them.
And this is a reinforcement learning
agent trained playing this live in your
browser. And we have these for pretty
much all these environments up to like,
you know, this miniature version of
Dota. We've got neural MMO, which is
like a massively multi- aent big
environment with lots of agents in
it. So we do ultra high performance
reinforcement learning. Uh, and I stream
all the dev for this.
It's all open source. Can play around
with it. And
uh yeah, big open source
project. Most of the time when I'm
streaming, I'm working on like some
little fiddly bit of infrastructure or
another, but this is how we build
Could have sworn there was one that
doesn't have
a method zero cuz that should be lower
overhead.
zero. Yeah. So, this maybe is a little
better.
Oh, obviously because it's just a pylon.
Okay. I forgot it wasn't a fancy object.
Yeah, that's easy. That is easy.
I hope this actually built
correctly. We'll see.
I mean, this is the only possible source
of overhead. I could
think it's still not any really faster
correctly cuz this wouldn't work
otherwise, right?
like okay so the other option here is
that the other possibility is it's just
it injected a
uh it injected a function
void injected. I mean a compiler that
I'm not familiar
with. Let's just go
um arg by arg here. So I'll highlight
this one at the bottom. This is what
we're comparing to.
Sign compare D and debug G2 wall G stack
protector format security
G oh I
think uh then you have the I for
This look the same to
me. What about the link arcs?
F B symbolic. Yeah, these are the same
arcs. Um, how is that possible?
everything. That really bothers me
because I would think it should be the
opposite.
Maybe. Um, hang
on. I'm going try it with
like maybe there's just something
screwing.
Yeah. Well, now these
match, but now I'm just timing
Python. I mean, there's nothing I can do
about that. Do I think that's going to
be a problem more generally?
It's got to just be like that one extra
pointer lookup,
be. Yeah. Well, we'll think about that
going forward. At least we have it
running and it's like the Perf is very
close. But actually, Syon for Perf
pretty dang good. Python Scython gets uh
gets a very good grade actually on the
Perf
side. Kind of surprised. I figured there
would be uh at least like some amount of
overhead.
MMO. How hard is that going to be? That
shouldn't be that hard, right?
mil. If I do
And we're just going to copy this whole
freaking
thing. This is temporary anyways, you
know. We're only going to keep the uh
the new one once we're done with this.
This is just a quick
test. Well, that's a little tricky,
isn't it?
Yeah, we're going to have to make a few
changes to make that work.
Honestly, I think instead of doing
uh both at once, we're going to have to
do leave it like this.
So now we can run this
test
whenever. And now we're going to have to
Oh, you know what? Maybe we can actually
do this. Hang
About to start my masters. Want to get
into RL. Any
tips? Quick start guide.
There you
go. That will be much much easier to
follow than uh most of the tutorials out
there. It's a lot less math and it's a
lot more like these are the things that
you should probably understand, these
are the things that matter, these are
the things that
don't. And this it's not just this post,
right? It links you to some papers and
stuff. It like tells you what papers to
read, but it's a pretty small set of
them. This is what I give to all our new
contributors as well.
I miss something. Not Not really. Um, we
got Pong nicely bound. The Perf is
like maybe 5% off or whatever between
them and I can't figure out why. So, I'm
doing neural MMO to see if that makes a
difference.
Oh, wait. This is
also Dang
it. Yeah. So, here's the uh the deal
with Syon, right? It actually seems I'll
have to test with neural MMO, but the
overhead actually seems even lower than
I thought. So, Sython's plenty fine.
Um, is that a good place to start
helping? Uh, it depends how much you
like fiddling with thousands of lines of
C. This is very much more infrastructure
side. So, what I did, and this is like
brand new, right?
There's this nbinding.h H file which
it's 470 some odd lines right and this
is a general purpose
um binding essentially that can take a
very very short per environment C file
and give you compatible vectorzed and
everything uh Python interface very low
overhead very clean and so compared to
what we had before if I look at like
pong even for pong, right? You had to
have this Syon file. We have 100 some
odd lines of
Syon. Okay. And now what we
have is this binding file and this is
all we have for Pong. And I'm hoping we
can make this even
shorter. So I'm trying to reduce the
amount of boiler plate that we need.
Yeah.
Um, now I didn't do this before because
it was actually kind of hard to write
that binding file and there's still
stuff I'm working on. But yeah, this is
kind of the latest thing if you're
really interested in infraide, you can
do that. Um, generally, you know, we've
got all sorts of MS in development that
probably need some nudges getting
merged. If you want to do Mside stuff
and if you want to do science side
stuff, then there tons of ablations and
things to run.
What would you first time contributors?
I almost always tell you to make an
environment
because it should not take you very long
to make like a simple environment.
Ideally, you do something
um that you can do like in a couple of
days even. Depends on your level of
proficiency. if you're already like a
good low-level dev, but you might
literally be able to knock it out in a
few hours. And uh ideally, you make
something also that's like actually an
interesting environment for Puffer. Now,
technically, I've already given this one
out to other people, but uh I don't
think they're actually going to do it
because I haven't heard anything back in
like several weeks.
Something like this would be a really
quick and easy to implement RL
environment and it would be kind of
cool voids. Yeah, it's like this basic
flocking sim. It's it's really like
silly, but you can see it kind of
produces these cool types of behaviors.
So something like this would be fun to
have as an
environment. You know, you could load
the puffer up as well as the asset. It
would be fun. And this could be like a
cool little
environment. Sometimes it doesn't take
much, right, to make like a really cool
environment that's actually useful for
research. Like my snake environment here
is maybe 200 lines of logic, maybe even
shorter. And it's really fun to watch
this and see and rabb. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Definitely definitely look at the way
that we build our environments and build
it that way because otherwise you're
going to be sad and
confused, but it's really not that much
code. like I don't know well you've
probably told me before but I don't
remember your if you do lowle
um
but here this is
snake this is the code for
snake most of this is logging actually
all this logging code gets deleted in
the new version of our code I did do
lowle c then you're in the right spot
because like we do we do brain dead Easy
C. All right, we do like really brain
dead easy C. Um, so this is the whole
this is how you compute observations.
Here's the snake code. It's like 150
lines of actual logic and that's
it. Embedded stuff is with an insane
make build system. That sounds not fun.
We currently have build sh.
Um, I have somebody campaigning to try
to get CMake into our is part of our
build system. I've been attempting to
resist
cmake, but yeah.
Um,
All right, that's how you build
snake. That's
it. So, it's it's just this little tiny
shell script. This is all it is. And
then in uh for the actual version that's
bound to Python, you just have to add it
to the
setup.py. So like you know you just add
it to this and you're done.
Also, I don't I also have to set up the
Python binding. Yeah. So, that's that
Syon file that you saw, which we're
working to get rid of, right? But, you
know, for now, you can still use the
Syon. You can try this crazy thing that
I have in dev if you want. Um, either
way, it's pretty easy like cuz it's kind
of the same code. It's just like redoing
the header in Syon and then defining all
the
methods. I wrote a map fn modified from
snake and I'm reading your
archive. Map fn. What's a map
fn? Reading your archive article.
Archive article is super old, I will
say. Um, let me find you the blog post.
This blog post has I guess the newer
stuff. It's not there's not much detail
here though. I guess in the 20
post I do more of this on
X. Oh yeah, this is just a short
article. I guess the technical stuff is
still mostly correct from the
archive. Multi-agent pathbinding. Okay,
cool. Oh, somebody just submitted multi-
aent like a multi- aent like cooperative
uh is it
common common resource problem
Awesome. So, somebody just PR this. This
is like a common resource problem
environment. Which branch should I
branch off of? Um, if you want to do
like the Syon one the way it is and then
I'll help you upgrade it once I finish
this. You can just do it off of 20. But
uh you will be merging it to dev
anyways. So it's just really a matter of
if you want to deal with me breaking
stuff on dev or not. But regardless, the
PR is going to end up going to dev. So
if you want to play with the new uh the
new binding stuff, it's in dev. If not,
and you just want something to like work
for now, you can probably do 20.
Look at this multi-agent got stuck at
step
transitions. Wait, step transitions from
C to gym ops. If you link me the code, I
will uh I can look at that for you.
What's the M called?
This is CPR. Common was it? No. C CRP
CPR common pool resource or something.
It's in the dev
branch. Hello. I'm just faffing new MS.
Trying simple platformers like game game
M. Wondering if you actually run drawing
as part of your steps. No, Ray is only
for
rendering. You don't want to run as part
of your step.
The MV recommended to me is
Boyds. B O I Ds.
How do you make sure that there's no
drawing happening? You don't call um you
don't call the init window uh in like
this main setup. You only call it when
you make the client and you don't make
the client unless you call render. So if
you look at the way that we have this in
our any of our M's, you'll see it.
like snake is a nice one for multi- aent
but uh if you just want general
purpose demo of really really simple
n ray is not called during training at
all yes that is
correct so you have this make client
function that inits ray this doesn't get
called unless you actually go make the
client so squared is the demo end this
is in docs as well for like new
environments. Uh it points you to this.
This is the simplest possible
environment. It's 130 lines of
code and um you know most of that's just
setup and
cleanup, right? It matches my
expectation. It
should eventually we'll probably figure
out at least some way to
do kind of okay pixel based training.
Um, but for now it's really it's so much
slower it's not even worth
bothering. Like why would we train on a
simple pixel rendered end when we can
train way faster on a much more complex
and interesting partially observed local
state
task. You're kind of just throwing it's
kind of like you're encoding to pixels
and then you're training something to
decode back to local state, right?
You're kind of just throwing away
compute.
And like there's nothing magical about
pixels either. It's it's just like yeah,
it'll work the same on pixels or without
pixels. It's just you throw away a bunch
of
compute. Dreamer, Atari, Deep might have
a separate path doesn't take advantage
of. Well, Dreamer V3 is also kind of
borderline scientific fraud with uh some
of the stuff in there. I mean, that's a
little bit exaggerated. That's probably
a little bit harsher than I should be,
but uh they did kind of waste 10,800
hours and uh a bunch of work that we did
kind of like showing that their methods
they still work, but they don't work at
all for the reasons that they say they
work.
up. So this is our nerves paper from two
years
ago. I'll link this. So all those fancy
tricks they say that are like really
general and helpful. Yeah, none of them
work. So somehow the world model part
works, but those tricks are just like
random stuff that they made up that
don't do anything.
Yeah, something like this
is something like this should
work. But this make vec thing is not
going to be
it? Is C++ okay? Uh, we don't currently
accept PRs in C++. We do all our stuff
in save. If you're trying to make your
own M for your own purposes, C++ is
perfectly fine. I just don't want to
deal with it because as soon as I open
the door to C++, I open the door to like
floodgates of crazy, you know, crazy C++
library stuff and build system
shenanigans I don't want to deal with.
And um if you look at the way we build
our
environments like
Okay, this thing is in
C. This thing is written in C. It's
really really easy to build stuff like
this in C if you look at the way we do
it. Like it's not hard at all to do
this. And like a lot of the stuff that
you think you want, you don't even want.
Like you don't want hashmaps a lot of
the time because the lookups are slow.
you want like flat indexed arrays. You
don't really want vectors because again
dynamic memory like you kind of just
want the thing implemented this way
anyways. Yeah, I don't know. At this
point in my life, I do not want to deal
with C++ shenanigans. I just don't want
to deal with it.
Maybe that's not a great reason, but me,
you know,
Okay, so I need these log items, which
is going to be slightly
annoying. Oh, yeah. I need a lot
of I need a lot of things. Actually,
these are just the args to neural MMO.
Can't find the environment when I look
up
voids. No, Boyds is the Wait, you can't
find B O I D S
BS. this
thing there are a lot of implementations
of it. It's it should be like a very
very short piece of
code. Yeah. Note that this one won't be
on a grid, right? This is a continuous
one, so it's not going to be on a grid.
We have examples of continuous M's,
though. Hey,
Weston. Look at that. Greeting everybody
new
Oh my jeez. Look at
this. Look at this signature. That is
gross.
What's a good example of a continuous
M? P would
do. I mean, there's no real difference
other than like you don't need a grid,
so you don't make one,
right? Um, we have lots of Ms that like
I think breakout supports continuous and
discrete actions as well.
Just continue. I'm still in
grid. Yeah, I just look at Pong for now.
I'm trying to think if we have a multi-
aent continuous
one. I think I was going to do
multi-agent continuous snake, but I
didn't.
So yeah, you can just look at the pawn
one.
also looking some of the M's but the C
files don't they're in theh files so the
C files are just for the local demos and
we also compile the web demos off of the
C files it's you should think of it as a
header only
implementation like the C is just a demo
file the C doesn't even get used when
you call it from Python. Python just uh
imports
theh. I do suggest devbing uh writing
the C file first though because it's
really nice to just dev in pure C and
then not have to deal with the Sython
bindings. That actually gets a little
bit easier once I merge this new stuff
in because it's becomes easier to debug
through Python if you want to. But
there's still not much reason to do that
when you can just debug through C and
have um you know everything being C with
better compile messages and
up. There we
go. I don't know what that was about.
files. You shouldn't need
them. I mean, the way we're using them,
you shouldn't need them. You literally
import one file.
I think there are a few environments
that like maybe they import like map
data as a separate.h or like some small
thing as a separate.h page, but then
it's
like, yeah, nothing should be getting
included by multiple places.
Like if you're including the same file
in multiple case uh multiple places
you've already probably over complicated
I mean, I guess it's partially that the
dev is somewhat opinionated in sense in
the sense that like I set stuff up the
way I want to, but I also set stuff up
to like really really encourage people
to keep stuff simple because there's
just there's no need to get fancy with
any of this stuff. It's like so much
easier to
maintain like just brain dead sea with
like neurommo 3 is one file and any
first year undergrad can read it like
after they've taken their first systems
course. It's that easy. So like what's
the point of making stuff fancier when
it just it works? Yeah, you shouldn't
need to import stuff all over the place,
right? Yeah, that's the key is you
shouldn't need to import stuff all over
the place.
Yeah, the goal is that puffer lip gets
like more condensed over time, not
less. There's some like gross third
party dependencies, but I don't know,
eventually maybe puffer just turns into
pufferlib.py.
just end up with like a 30,000line
Python file that does everything. That'd
be kind of
cool. It wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world
either. I mean, how funny would it be
though if like all the RL utils you
need, it's just like, yeah, here's a
file. Have you heard of Tiny Grad? Yeah.
So, I like that their code is condensed,
but they tend to golf a little bit much,
right? We don't
golf. Like, I'll almost never even use
if you're using like a double list
compression, you're already going it's
like it's already too much.
Yeah. See, like the thing that I found
that is the most effective way to
prevent a library from spiling out of
hand is to just paste files together.
Because like as soon as you start
separating stuff into a bunch of
different files and directories, people
like lose track of what does what and
they start writing a ton of redundant
code. But if you kind of force everybody
to just sit there looking at all their
code, then they write less redundant
stuff. That's literally what I do for
clients as well. Like I'll get handed
some ridiculous growth research
repository and the first thing I'll do
is I'll just like paste all the files
together like in import order, right?
Like okay, this imports that. Let's
paste that in. And then that imports
that. Let's paste that in. And then I
end up with like a big blob of code. And
then I go through and say, "That's
redundant. That's redundant. That's
redundant. Delete. Delete. Delete." And
I end up with like half the
code. It's a really stupid and really
effective technique.
not that's
unfortunate. Dang. I thought the reward
was going to be summed, but it's not.
It's just for the one step
does require a few uh substantial
changes to the end
here to make the new logging work.
Though it is ultimately shorter.
This didn't print anything up. So type
combat element
propi
market
sell
combat. All right.
Dang. I
actually Oh, that's
annoying. Do you seriously need both of
these? I think you do.
something. Oh, it gets called from in
tick, I guess.
Oh yeah, I can play it. It's slow
because it's running a unoptimized Xener
on that, but it
works
cool. Now, I think that the
um the way it works now
I have to make this render
if must reset before making the client
which is fine.
go. I don't see the neural mode 3
build in here.
I wish I knew why it t that it's really
obnoxious.
Uh, and then the delta. I
guess delta is an
terminals. Oh, and I forgot that we no
longer need I literally do
observations, ops, actions, rewards,
terminals, and then truncations.
Oh, and then this player is flat. Enemy
is
flat. None of this does anything, right?
five. And then these are mandatory
keyboard arts.
Okay, so we have width equals height
equals num.
Width equals height
equals num players, num enemies, num
resources, weapons, gems, tiers,
levels, titus, enemy
item, x.
Wait, enemy respawn.
Item respawn
ticks. X window, Y
window, combat level, prop level, item
level, word
market. All
right, that's still not going to work
because the D types are probably wrong.
We'll have to get that error
out some point.
ins players int. Enemies is int. Resorts
is int and gems int. Here's int.
Oops. Int teleport is float. This is
int. Item response
int. X windows
int. Y window is int.
Combat is float is float. Float float
These also have to be the same order,
don't they?
We'll clean this up so that you get like
actually good errors on this. But for
now, I just want to make it work with
height, num players, num
enemies, num resources, num weapons,
gems, tiers, levels, tightest respawn,
item respond window, Y window, combat
level,
prof. Okay. And over here I've got
width, height, players,
enemies, resources, weapons, gems. Here
is level. This enemies to respawn X
Y combat from item market. Okay.
And then I
have int
int float float float
float. That looks correct to me
actually.
There you go. So that actually gives you
uh the type error.
I think I'm just screwing up the
signature on this.
It would be nice to get
um actual data.
Okay, so
teleportitis. Was it teleportitis enemy
and item respawn text?
runs now. I don't think I've handled
multi- aent, have I? I don't think I've
handled multi-
aent. Maybe I
Technically it should be handled. Come
to think of
it. See you have to allocate player.
That's fine.
up? Yeah, I just have to move this up.
That's easy.
this. I got to say this is really really
nice being able to debug through Python.
normally that would be really annoying
to figure out why it's seging in Python
but not in
It
runs and it's a bit faster than uh the
original. Just a little bit, but it is a
little bit faster.
Perfect. Neural MMO 3.
Everyone neural MMO 3.
As Spencer, I just ported neural MMO 3
to the new binding API.
Yep, we'll figure out how to do that.
But um this is the new binding for
neural
MMO. This is all the binding code.
Yeah, isn't
it? Yeah, I still have to fix the
wrong. We're going to get that even
smaller. Also, you want to see something
that's missing from this
file. Let's see if is there anything
missing from this file that you can see.
Maybe uh this side by side will help jog
your memory a little
bit about the horrors which were
inflicted. All right.
Ready? Look at all this login
And then uh look log is literally just a
static
array. All right. And then what's add
log do
this. Now I might still be wanting to
find a way to like get it into a strct.
So, you know, I can do log dot instead
of log of like this. But this is really
not
bad. It's pretty cool though, right? So,
how the hell did I manage to do
that? Well, it's kind
of it's kind of cool.
So
um this is the log function right
here. So this iterates over all those
keys that you
defined and it iterates over all the log
values and it puts them to a py it
averages them and puts them into a
Python
dictionary. You've been cooking? Indeed
I have.
Well, to be fair, I was mostly cooking
on Saturday and then I burnt myself out
and ended up playing Hades for the next
like day and a
half. You can blame Captain for this
because that wouldn't have happened if I
if he hadn't made me buy this. All
right, there's a reason I didn't buy one
of these.
because like I know myself. I won't play
I won't download and play a game on
keyboard and mouse if I know it'll be
better on a
controller and it's
fast. So far it looks like Pong took a
uh Pong took a tiny performance hit like
5% or whatever and this one seems like
it's 5 to 10%
faster. There shouldn't be any perf hit
and if anything it should be faster.
This is like no overhead whatsoever.
This is like the least amount of binding
you can possibly have. This is literally
like one Python object, which is the
Python object that you convert back to
the Python
API. So, of anything we could possibly
do, this should be the lowest
overhead. It pretty cool. It is pretty
cool.
There are a few gotchas at the moment
that you know it's new. We'll um we'll
fix the gotchas.
Look at
that. Now, let's see if that hurts Perf
at
all. That might hurt Perf a little bit
having to do that
conversion. Exactly.
Right. And there's no side.
So the entire Syon file is
gone. That's the dependency gone as
well. Like you don't need Syon at all.
Oh, also you can debug through it. So if
you run GDB and you get like a seg fault
that only happens in Python, if you just
run the thing with GDB now, it'll stop
you right when it's seg fault and you
can transparently debug the
C. I've been doing some stuff, you know.
I've been doing some stuff.
test. Yeah. So, still slightly faster
than the uh the original
Syon. That is 1.6 6
million steps per second. And if I go to
pong, yeah, you can GDB through the C
from
perfectly. I've been working on it. I've
been freaking working on it, you
know. There's
Pong. So, for whatever reason, the Syon
is a little bit faster on Pong. I don't
know how because what we're doing now is
like actually no
overhead. I honestly I suspect that
we're measuring like Python loop speed
or something stupid at this point
because this fast
mil, bro. Just increased my M building
speed. Yeah, man. I try to make nice
things
like I'll show you as well. So, this
is I mean this is what it took, right? I
had to get into the Python
API and this is not perfect yet. There's
still some gotchas. It's going to be,
you know, good soon. Don't worry about
it. Um, but yeah, you just have these
functions. Now, here's the crazy thing
about it. So, this reset
function, you don't actually know what
these are right now because these are
the reset function of the end you're
using, which is not a thing that you can
do in uh a statically typed compiled
language like this. You can't do this.
Okay. And watch
this. So in the C function here, you
have to import them in a specific order.
So you put this and then after you've
defined all these macros, then you
include the binding and then the binding
knows what functions you
have. So you can put whatever you want
here and you just bind to it.
So you can name the ends whatever you
want. You can name your step, reset, and
render functions whatever you want. As
long as they have the same signature,
you can just bind to
them. And then for keyword args, all you
have to do to make keyword args list
work in Python is you have to define the
names of all of them. So these are the
strings. And then you just do this
annoying parse thing here.
So this is the only thing but this is
the only thing that you have to do right
this is the only thing you got to
bound and you know I'm going to probably
see if I can find a way to make it a
little easier down the
line but this is a huge upgrade still
I mean the debugging alone is like so
nice. No more like oh it hits a seg
fault 10 minutes into training. You just
run it with GDB.
How you handling? Well, neural MMO 3 is
a hard M to handle, isn't it? Watch
this. Neural MMO3 is like complicated,
right? you have different numbers of
agents per m and stuff like that. This
is why we give you two
functions.
Oops. You see how all these arguments
are like different for
n? No worries. You do your
initialization in a loop. This looks
like the Syon loop,
right? Except it's in Python
now. And it init all the M's. But then
you call
You can also mix and match the vector
and the non-vector API. So like you can
call you can just init all these m and
then you can call step on individual M's
or you can call vest step and do the
loop and
What if you uh what if you don't need to
do all this stuff because you have like
you know most our our environments have
the same init function for everything
right all
right this is the one for palm you just
call init vec and it passes the same
arguments to
everything and then you use the vector
API no loop
So, this is now the whole palm
code. And you know, we're going to see
if we can get this even
Also, are you ready for 6,000 years
worth of neural MMO on one
plot? There you go. 6,000 years worth of
neural MMO in one
plot. Each of these runs is 100 bill.
100 bills 2,000 years of
gameplay. A little more
actually. And that's
soda with a perfectly smooth learning
curve.
stuff. I see we have a fair few folks on
uh YouTube and Twitch. So, good time to
mention if you're interested in all this
stuff and you want to help me out for
free, just start the repo. Really,
really helps when people start the repo.
And if you want to get involved with
Dev, join the Discord.
All right. Um, I should probably run
training on this thing, huh?
Yeah, these are not the right params.
So, let me go grab those. Good lord. So,
I forgot. Does Nural have a bunch of
intermediate
rewards? Not a bunch. So, actually,
these ones are totally redundant right
here. Let me just This should be this
because it's the rewards get clipped
anyways.
So
here, this is the reward it gets. It
gets a level any it gets one reward
anytime it levels up or gets like a
better item and then it gets a negative
reward for dying. That's it.
run. Uh, I'm not getting all the logs
back
though. Not getting the logs back. Hang
There we
go. That's like in the expected
range. Return death doesn't make sense
to me.
Probably this isn't getting
zeroed. It is definitely not getting
zeroed. Given neural MMO 3 is such a
long train run. Do you still find a
kneeling works? I think my
implementation of a kneeling is broken
at the moment. So I got to go I got to
get back to you on that one.
Let me just check. I want to make sure I
don't screw this up in the original.
this? Uh, I thought that was the right
syntax.
Okay, now return death depth is always
negative one.
And combat levels starting to creep up
just a tad.
and n is back to something
reasonable. If episode length is
40, they say I've got 12,000 of these in
here. Sounds reasonable to
me. How quickly is return supposed to
come off the ground?
Ah, because this is before
I Yeah, this is before I changed some
stuff. It's like 200 mil. It's supposed
to do
something. Oh, and it is
increasing. Yeah, it is
running a sanity. Seeing if even if it
can even figure out reaching the
goal with no collision penalty.
Maybe. But uh well actually maybe. Yeah.
I mean, it should get a uh it should get
like if it's going to collide in reset,
it should get the negative reward on
reset, I would say.
Want to verify connected all of variable
num agents. Make sure I initialize
everything. Yep, you can do that. Very
good. That's a chunky PR right
there. Look at this chunker.
offer
575K. Holy, it's fast. Look at that.
It's fast.
All right. So simple run just to make
sure that uh the train
curves
576k train on neural MMO is
obscene. It's freaking fast.
Well, so we will see how that
goes.
Okay, it is just past
6. I'm trying to think what I want to do
because I got to get dinner soon.
Let me just see what B's been doing just
to make sure he's not doing something
crazy with uh cuz he I think he sent a
PR
in. Make sure B's not doing something
crazy.
Okay. Well, I'm not merging broken
breakout. I'll wait until you fix
params. It's a little sketchy to
do. He made initial bind for
this. Uh change
add the terminals, add the
logs. Yeah, I mean, he pretty much did
um did this exactly the
way I would uh I'd
here. Uh, you should no longer need to
do this.
fine. Net
back.
Okay. I think that's going to be that's
going to be it for now because I'm
getting pretty hungry. Uh I may or may
not come back after dinner for a bit of
dev. Depends on how I'm feeling here.
But
overall, new end binding system now
works for the most complicated end
puffer lib. So, it's going to work for
everything else just fine. It's a little
faster. It fixes debugging. It
eliminates a whole bunch of boiler
plate. There's still some improvements
that I want to think about for it, but
overall pretty darn
good. Yeah, overall pretty darn good.
Let's just double check. Make sure that
this is actually
going. Okay. So, this curve looks a bit
different from before, but it's going to
be scaled
differently. And actually, it's supposed
to look like this one, not this one.
I may be mildly concerned, but I think
we just have to let it run. I think we
just have to let this
run and I will uh come back and check
it. All right. So, for folks
watching, puffer.ai for all the things
want to help us out, start the GitHub.
It would be awesome to hit 2K on this
pretty soon. Join the Discord if you
want to get involved. It's
discord.gg/puffer or click the button.
And you can also follow me on X for more
reinforcement learning content where I
post a lot of my latest thoughts on
stuff I'm working on as well as some
news and you also get stream
notifications. If you're looking to get
into RL, I highly suggest my quick start
guide. It's here as well as on X. This
is what I link to all new contributors.
And this is a excellent way to get
started in RL. pretty much all you need
is a decent programming background.